[Music]
[Music]
is helping us out today because we got a
4:20 in the morning without our alarm
clock and it's a good thing too because
we're meeting a fishing guide at 5 in
the morning to go do some japanese-style
micro fishing I'm not 100% sure on all
the details but I know it guys meeting
us I know how much it costs and we're
gonna figure out the rest what your name
is Matsu you keep masaaki yuasa yuki
Mizuki it'll eat pizza they're gonna
help us out we're gonna do some
japanese-style fish in here which I know
nothing about so this is gonna be a
learning opportunity and Tommy is just
gonna be crazy Tommy and hopefully he'll
have some fun too
alright let's go fishing so this kind of
fishing we're gonna be doing is talk
tomorrow
we drove about 30 45 minutes out of
Kyoto and we're here on the shores of
Lake Biwa and we're gonna do sufficient
jumping all over the place yeah we're
here at the fishing spot and we're gonna
fish for something called an igloo there
we go now we waiting look at the size of
that he gets on the camera I'll have to
throw it away and buy a new one
well yeah these guys are hooking me up
man I got myself a TV so only give me
these little ball of rice covered in
seaweed usually with the surprise inside
salmon whoo this one has salmon inside
only Guinea time
[Music]
tell me you want to reel this one in
fish is taking full power yeah it's her
first me going
yeah it's a pirate knee gooey cuz he's
missing an eye that makes him a pirate
are goes Oh guys this is awesome those
fish
fight hard man they're really a great
fish and we're just having a kick in the
pants I think you've been on the side
what pound line the way up holy mackerel
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is a big car that was my first
Japanese car yes that's a nice car
that is a beautiful Japanese car hmm so
we didn't have a scale for that carp so
we measured him it was 86 centimeters
long that is a long fish it's a big boy
I roughly estimate him mid to upper-20s
I've now caught 20-plus pound fish on
three continents I told these guys I
wanted to catch as many different
species as I could sample is much
different type of fishing as I could
so we've caught an eye an eye you we've
got an ego a massive carp and now we're
gonna go for tanaga tone argh oh yes ten
I go tonight I have no clue what this
thing looks like or what it's like I'm
excited to find out we're gonna hop in
the car go up to a different spot and
try a different species of fish
that's when we know we've been
successful Lake Biwa thing is beautiful
and massive rice field the countryside
so right now we're at another bridge
right here next to a farm field we've
got a little stream that dumps in and
it's carved out a little deep spot there
and we're gonna fish for tanaga
and the is to Naugle like to spawn on
clamshells apparently when they spawn
they've got really beautiful spawning
colors well I can see yeah I can see
little fish it's something about this
big something about this big right right
there look at that that looks like a
daze that is cool alright that is my
first time paloma to say how elusive
that's look at this hook this looks like
a size 26 maybe a little bit of blood
worm on it some split shot and here's my
bobber check that out isn't that cool
cuz it's got the black on it yeah oh
that's beautiful
well that is species number four and
five so five species of fish today look
at this isn't this beautiful
[Music]
we're like a breeze
oh he's green that smell
oh it's a man - no go this is the male
and this is a female all right six
species in one morning not too bad not
too bad I am have a good old time way to
go Tommy's the frog catching champion
come on Tommy
no more products you gotta go getting
tired
alright alright guys we're gonna stop
and buy some takoyaki which is like
balls of dough with octopus inside with
mayonnaise and seaweeds that one it's
really good see these little balls of
dough with a bit of octopus in the
middle and and traditionally you eat
them when they're too hot then you burn
your mouth and that's what we do every
single time most Japanese people have
third-degree burns inside their mouth
from eating takoyaki we got octopus in
our belly yep Bacardi Swift all in our
hands we're ready to go alright guys
we're gonna try to catch a Japanese
catfish now they look a little bit like
a wels catfish a little bit deal like we
are tired we are sweaty and I think it's
time to get this boy home but we had a
great time guys thank you very much
got back home we got changed spruced up
a little bit we're gonna go see my wife
and meet her for dinner all right we're
gonna go find Becca and some friends of
hers and we're gonna see about doing
some dinner yeah I may have accidentally
bought chicken liver yeah that's just
good that Liaquat OD I bought for lunch
today turned out to be a liver part of
it turn delivered Tommy wasn't a fan
plus it was like two days old liver
that's been the Sun for half the day so
they got him a banana and some other
stuff that Compton down to my wife's got
a couple of colleagues that she wanted
to show to this yakiniku place we went
yesterday so we're gonna go do that
again it's a buffet so we can mix it up
a little bit oh yeah tasty as always bad
as ever today me and Tommy we're gonna
do a lot of sightseeing and we're gonna
get some breakfast you hungry yeah let's
go on a bike
yeah there are thorn bushes in the
grocery store where we wanted to get
breakfast is it open yet so we're gonna
go ride to a fishing spot and check it
out
see if there's any fish in there and by
time we get done doing that the store
should be open to see the Japanese
people when they're working outside
they'll wear a towel around their neck
it's good to help whites wipe sweat away
and keep the sweat from dripping down
your back alright guys we're here on a
bridge above the river and I can see
some fish I saw about a 10 pound 12
pound carp swimming right there but I'm
looking for catfish Japan is such a
clean country here we are in Kyoto a
massive City the equivalent to like
Chicago or something and rivers just
gorgeous beautiful and looks so clean
often with these Japanese rivers when
the waters at normal levels there's a
bike path along the banks of the river
which is absolutely beautiful place to
travel but you can see from the walls
how much flooding they expect pun to
show Oh fishing for carp he's got a
bobber and some bread oh yeah nice okay
I talked to this guy and he fishes here
all the time and he showed me some great
pictures of about a twenty thirty pound
he caught here and a bunch of carp and a
few catfish Turtles crabs
pretty cool so definitely a decent carp
spot and he says there's plenty catfish
here too so I think I might try that
the other important thing I'm learning
is he's fishing with two rods so I'm
gonna assume that that's legal because I
cannot read the regulation hey let's see
if we can find some treasure in the in
the riverbank
you know Kyoto is an ancient city and
this is a very old river so I'm going to
just kind of walk along and see if we
can find any any old artifacts look at
there is old pottery yeah you can see
lots of pieces of pottery here but this
is an unusual find I believe that's a TV
don't think it works anymore though see
the water was really high here that
noise that's a bug called a cicada
we caught a semi in Japanese love the
cicadas in Japan they're so cool alright
let's go back to that grocery store
I love Japanese supermarkets yeah
ferocity breaks there you go two and a
half dollar peach they tell me this is
spaghetti and chicken nuggets you want
that spaghetti and chicken nuggets and
rice all right let's get you one of
those and go get me an onigiri
all right hurry up breakfast and some
snacks I want to go home and have some
Japanese cereal and fruit all right so
we've got cereal milk giant peach and
let's get some breakfast oh goody
speed-sew tummy
peach is called mobile in Japanese and
you know how to say I like beaches all
right buddy let's go get some fishing
gear
for fishing gear here all right we got
to pikachu rods one for Nathan and one
for Tommy yeah it's a perfect little
keep net for bluegill gonna get one take
these rigs out it's a it's a bobber than
the cebiche rig and a little basket for
chumming fish is Revo elites it's about
two hundred and twenty dollars so it's a
little bit cheaper than I think they are
in the US right now if you show them
your passport so that you're not a
resident it saves you all the sales tax
it's a great way to save a little money
if you're buying a big-ticket item now
I've got to figure out how to get all
this home while riding a bicycle
[Music]
like your bento bud all right good stuff
here's my lunch this is called Inari
sushi it's a sweet tofu skin wrapped
around rice this is Solman which is a
buckwheat noodle that's cold that you
dip into cold soy sauce it's great on
hot summer days this is one of my
favorite summer meals your trip like me
and Tommy have been having a ball but
poor wife here is actually working Becca
here gets to go do a little sightseeing
today but she still has to do a bit of
work unlike her husband she she actually
has to knuckle down and do something
every once in a while so we're gonna
listen to our audiobook while she works
we've been listening to Brandon
Sanderson's the Stormlight archive
series and it's like 40-something hours
of audio book for each one if they got
three three books series we've been
enjoying it a lot all right guys we're
gonna go do some sightseeing as a family
all three of us gets to get out and see
the town where Beck has been I
conferences so much so you guys excited
all right guys you'll Castle tell me
wanna go see a samurai castle
that's gonna be pretty cool Japanese
castles are pretty awesome tell me is
this a cool castle see that little fish
right there
that is not a carp I that is something
something but it doesn't have barbels on
its mouth yeah see there's more more
card right there Nijo castle or need
Jojo
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
look at that that is huge it's the time
are you happy with that you like that
well nice shave ice and rest hit the
spot
Tom you only hurt himself twice but we
got the chat with some very nice people
from Kyoto these castles are really cool
and kind of fun to go visit even if
you're not into historical stuff if
you're in Japan look around
odds are there's a castle nearby and if
not that there's plenty of shrines and
temples got a misting tunnel to cool us
off mmm I'm getting wetter cuz I'm
taller that's nice
no gun show oh gosh oh yes sir you've
got the Emperor's Palace here and at the
same time he had the Shogun's Palace
over there the Shogun basically started
a civil war where he became set himself
up as the leader and ruler of Japan but
he didn't depose the Emperor he did it
in the name of the Emperor and so
hierarchy is so important that even
though he overthrew the government he
didn't officially overthrow the
government you know it's a very very
Japanese thing to do
Palace and the park it sits in is pretty
big actually
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Tommy you have a core fund now well we
knocked out the Emperor's Palace in like
30 minutes we're gonna go hit the gion
district really quick and see what there
is to see maybe do a rickshaw ride maybe
grab some food yeah that's just fun to
do the official touristy thing for one
day we were sitting here trying to flag
down the taxi and we wave out a taxicab
it turns out it was the driver who
dropped us off and he's got passengers
with them anyways but he pulls over
really quick hops out hands Tommy a free
baseball cap and then here we are in the
gilliam district we're gonna go get a
rickshaw for about an hour tour and
we're about to make a very nice Japanese
man work very very hard
all right time you ready to do a
rickshaw ride and this is the moment
we're gonna hear his back break you
mother son dr. Seuss in Juarez Kodomo
Virginia nowadays una rima so
[Music]
if you think you guys got ripped legs
you don't have replace mr. Giamatti here
he's got ripped legs this is do desired
oh this is a Shinto shrine and this one
is is for people who are trying to quit
bad habits Greenpeace started started
here they brought the tea tree from
China
Kyoto's a very famous for its green tea
because of that he said last week the
river was so high that it was it was God
water was up to where people are eating
on the decks
domi demat City got out of the show
look at the mask up there how many times
some part trillion
take it easy dumb I thought now tell me
what we're gonna get is yaki soba it's
noodles noodles that they fry and they
put sausage and chicken in it a rickshaw
driver recommended this place for yaki
Siletz we're gonna give this a shot I
love me some yakisoba all right we're
gonna get some beef yaki soba
what do you watchin over there that is
proper yaki soba right there I've been
missing that
those taxis sure are nice they usually
can get anywhere you need to go in Coto
for about 15 u.s. dollars tipping is not
a thing here in Japan so don't even
worry about that saves you a lot of
money and so it's just very convenient
easy way to get around it's been another
beautiful day and we are exhausted
blissfully exhausted and we're gonna get
up at 4:30 in the morning whether we
want to or not so we better call it a
night and go to bed we'll see you guys
in the morning
well thanks for watching if you guys
enjoyed this video don't forget to check
out the part 5 of our 2018 world tour or
you do you have great adventures in
children Japan including going to a
monkey fills the mountain and Tommy gets
bitten by an owl thanks for watching and
don't forget to click Subscribe have a
great day
[Music]